foreign
show I'm your host Paul is awful and I'm
so excited to talk about Black Mirror
season six the show is returned and for
the next week we're going to be going
through every single episode to bring
you full ending explain breakdowns first
up is Joan is awful which centers around
a woman discovering that her entire life
has been turned into a quote-unquote
Netflix drama this showcases all of her
faults fantasies and it unearths every
Dirty Little Secret she has they also do
a big twist come the end which I'll talk
more about as we get further into it
extremely forth wall breaking it
actually has a number of different black
mirror and Netflix Easter eggs in it for
the first part of the video I want to go
through what they are and then from here
we'll go into its plot and meaning now
the opening when the title itself is
revealed is the same font as Netflix and
we learn that in this universe that it's
called streamberry we see the service
being accessed at several points and
there's lots of different titles that
you can catch on it you can see Locke
Henry truth aloud and this is a
documentary on episode 2 from this
season there's also Sea of Tranquility
which was first brought up during
nosedive and later in this season during
the episode Maisie day finding ripman is
a reference to Black Mirror bandersnatch
the calories is another Prime Minister
Michael Kellow from the national anthem
HotShots is from 15 million merits and
in that there was a show called bother
guts which involved beating fat people
that speech it here too there's a
documentary on Victorious scalane from
the episode White Bear and also one
about Ashley oh from Rachel Jack and
Ashley too finally you can catch your
project titled Junipero dreaming which
features similar imagery to the episode
Sanji napero now the idea of stream
Berry turning Jones life into a
documentary is of course a comment on a
number of things involving Netflix and
privacy in general Netflix have recently
been accused of turning serious events
into commercial Commodities that twist
the horrific into entertainment the
Jeffrey Dahmer show starring Evan Peters
had a lot of outcry from the families of
those that were murdered and there was
criticism at the time centered around
them turning things into these bingy TV
episodes making a murderer made their
Millions Tiger King was a massive
success but the people who featured in
these have often spoken out about how
much damage it caused Nigel exotic was
going to jail either way but the fame
given to the other people in the dark
hasn't really had its positives there's
this idea as well that bad people often
get given the spotlight more than the
good ones and this is of course also
reflected in Joan herself she's a cheat
mean boss and overall a kind of crappy
person still though there's a lot of
people like this that exist in the world
and some people who don't even hit the
thumbs up button on videos even though
it's free and it supports the channel a
lot she fires her employees meets with
her ex and confesses to her therapists
that she's sick of the vanilla lifestyle
not only is she perfect for a Black
Mirror episode but she's also perfect
for a stream Berry show too done due to
her not reading the terms and conditions
I think this also talks about what
people give up unintentionally online
people post way too much of their
personal lives on social media and you
really start to wonder who ends up
actually owning that you could say it's
the user but as we know these sites also
take things for themselves and sell them
onto companies that are after your data
this is to push ads normally but there
have been complaints that they use them
for other means no one reads the terms
and conditions and we're completely
unaware of what we're signing over they
also talk about the dangers of deep fake
technology as well whether it's learning
that hike has given her likeness so that
a quantum computer can create scenes
using her face there's a movie that's
just released that brings back some
detectors which I won't spoil but it's
definitely a comment on how we tend to
gravitate towards Stars even if they
have no involvement whatsoever himesh
Patel plays Krish and we also get Kate
Blanchard playing Joan and salma's
version I love the whole idea of the
likeness thing and they actually do a
very very clever meta joke at the
midpoint of the episode it's also sort
of talking about how content is now just
run by AI which is obviously a relevant
fear that's being used as one of the
many many reasons the writers strike is
happening in either way I love the whole
idea of them deconstructing the likeness
thing and they actually do a very very
clever meta joke at one point in the
episode Jones speaks to a lawyer and in
the adapted show she then gets played by
one me masaka and masaka actually
appeared in the Black Mirror episode
play test and the joke here is that
appearing in an earlier episode of Black
Mirror means that she signed her
likeness away to be used in other
episodes which is why she appears here
other Easter eggs include Sandy's phone
showing a social media app called
Smithereens and a newspaper has an
article saying grains going out of style
now a grain is a device from the entire
history of you and this allowed people
to record their entire day it led to
nothing but unhappiness with characters
obsessing over everything and having it
all held up on a microscope is something
that Jones subjected to on the back of
the newspaper we can also see that
there's an advert for tckr which is an
odd to the software company takisoft
tokisoft appeared in Black Mirror band a
snatch and I loved how this episode had
lots of ties to the Black Mirror
Universe now there's also a protest for
Michael smart at JFK and he was a local
politician in Demon 97. you can see now
that he's the PM of the UK and it's kind
of nicely building upon what happened in
that episode and while the episode also
brilliantly comments on is how shows are
over dramatized and elements are changed
and altered to make things appear a
certain way sure Joan she is pretty bad
but they still Elevate and change some
aspects of it to make her appear worse
the show and its depictions are what's
seen as the truth with everyone's
perception being that it plays out like
that it's a really good analysis of how
based on a true story in True Crime
dramas can often sway public opinion as
they tend to go for drama rather than
documenting the history all the
relationships she has end up falling
apart and this includes Rob Delaney's
Mark who can't be intimate with her this
is due to him overthinking the show and
how it will look in that and yeah it
just kind of a talk about how once
you're under the microscope you can't
stop thinking about it in the end Joan
ruins a wedding by chowing down on
Buster burgers and a laxative and yeah
kind of shows up and shits over the
whole event literally where things
happen at mine because I you should see
them more and my wife ended up marrying
but she realizes that if they want to
show then she's gonna go and give it to
them and this sort of becomes a get out
of jail free card for Joan with the
company now covering for their brand new
star this could also be a further
comment on Hollywood and how they go
above and beyond to protect their Stars
movies and shows from any controversy
might not be yeah but there's more
things you can point to recently in in
certain films where this has been going
on now Hayek is furious area like this
has been led to a character doing this
and it leads to some stuff I never
thought I'd hear her say I mean doesn't
my have any rights absolutely
hilarious
also important to bear in mind the guy
he has played by Rich vulture who is an
actor and and that kind of plays another
twist we get later on anyway hi it goes
up to Jones which is where they meet
face to face
it didn't
um actually think that you would come to
welcome to my home it's weird watching
this because you kind of imagine what it
would be like seeing a TV show like this
in real life when we're kind of seeing
this as a TV show in real life that's
about a real Thrive TV show which is
then made by AI ends up going into a
complete tear down on Netflix on Netflix
and we learned that George Clooney has
been brought back which we're getting
some relevant uh move recent movie
social commentary there and they break
into the streamberry offices which is
when Joan hears that she was just a
guinea pig and that they're planning on
running it on more and more people Chao
was picked because she was an average
person but even just an average life can
be changed into entertainment this is
done if it's edited correctly and given
star power by a big actor we also see
more from the is awful franchise and I
believe there's a title card here for
Charlie which is a reference to Charlie
Brooker bursting into a room with
Michael Sarah working as a tech we get a
big twist to learn that Joan isn't even
the real and that she's the AI using the
likeness of Annie Murphy real-life clips
of her on the red carpet are used and
there's also a mention of her show which
is called shit's creek due there being
shows within shows within shows there
needs to be a top level to it all but
unfortunately for Joan she isn't on that
one in order for this show to work the
characters need to believe that they're
real so all our responses are programmed
to be the way we see them there are
theories that we could all exist in a
simulation without even knowing it and
in the end Jon does what John would do
which is destroy the computer after it
goes down we see the real Joan with
Annie Murphy now in Hike's place and the
pair obviously made because of the whole
church thing happening in Real Life Joan
has finally managed to free herself
though and we see that having her life
basically broken down allows her to
reassess things and see what's actually
important due to her actions she has a
tag on her leg but she feels like the
main character in her life finally she's
found importance in the things that she
once stuck for granted due to losing
their man we find her working away in a
coffee shop that she's now opened
visited by Annie It's actually nice to
get a happy ending in Black Mirror
because you don't get them often and
that closes out the episode on a very
high note a huge alert to our partners
over at the streamer.com who've done a
massive review of all the episodes on
the show and that will be linked as the
top comment so if you want to read some
reviews then go over there and check
them out if you want to review it
yourself then obviously let me know your
thoughts on the episode below and I
can't wait to see if there's anything
I'm missing this because I'm sure there
is something anyway let me know your
thoughts in the comment section below
and if you want to support the channel
for as little as 99 cents a month then
please click the join button and as a
thank you you'll get early access to
videos every week if you want something
else to watch we've got a breakdown of
the flash on screen right now so
definitely head over there right after
this out of the way huge thank you for
saying through the video I've been Paul
and I'll see you next time take care
peace